in which picture is the cow beside the  little chicken here the little chick  choose one answer so which one do you  think it is  well over here they aren't beside each  other over here they are so i would pick  choice b  let's do another example  which elephant is behind the bricks  think about it which one is behind the  bricks a or b well in choice a the  elephant is in front of the bricks it's  in choice b that the elephant it looks  like it's hiding behind the bricks just  sneaking around all right i'm gonna go  with choice b  let's do one more example  which shape is below  this green rectangle over here  so if i look over here this is our green  rectangle and which one is below it well  we see this red triangle  so this is below the green triangle and  we are done